scp-682 versus scp-393  so many of the foundation's plans to  kill scp-682 have failed but maybe  that's just because they never wrote it  down in scp-393  this singularly unique day planner  scp-393 is a day planner that bonds to a  nearby subject and when they write their  plans into it they will soon develop a  complete memory of having achieved those  plans perhaps this could be used to  figure out how to kill 682 a d-class was  given the planner and asked to write  going to somehow defeat  scp-682 today the d-class was later  found comatose with a horrified  expression on their face and died  shortly after a defeated note from a  young research assistant on the test  file reads it was worth a shot